/
toutes façons à tous on les adore soit
van damme soardi stallone s'est toujours
énorme epita son mec c'est des rockstars
donc voilà on peut on ne faut pas les
rater quoi ces cds qui sont ces décès
d'amy de quoi s'il a une petite
préférence peut-être si vraiment falloir
trouver un trait stallone et
aujourd'hui il ya peut-être un petit
surplus pour chardy s'était vite envie
de dix ans qu'on l'a pas vu donc à la
grosse attente autour de changer n'est
guère au toit d'où vous venez du doubs
moi je comptais d'accord de franche
comté vous êtes là depuis qu à l'heure
aujourd'hui utérine lui 8h30 ok donc ça
y est la tante grandi vous avez hâte
qu'ils arrivent à bouillonner ces kits
ont préféré dans tous ses talons estatof
s'étalonner statham tu stallone tu l'as
vu dans quoi bas dans rocky expander des
autres îles et puis j'adore et le
premier alors le premier expendables
that avait plus bah oui c'est être
beaucoup d'action cuba est alors
celui-là tu espères qu'est-ce que tu
attendes celui là tu espères que ça sera
à quoi encore vaincu l'explosion qui
beaucoup tuerie thème bien les tueries
on voit avec une affiche de total recall
tu as une petite préférence pour l'un
d'entre eux ah oui quand-même pour
choisir les guerres parce que voilà ça
fait longtemps qu'on l'a pas vu et que
ça fait plaisir le plaisir de le revoir
au cinéma ça alès dans le sud une 100 km
j'arrivais à midi ce matin en fait à
cette heure d'abord à leur hôtel les
voir et puis après je suis venu ici à
midi d'accord est tu les a croisés à
l'hôtel non 26 allemands dont j'ai
déjeuné à l'hôtel mais
je n'ai pas eu un déjeuner à l'hôtel
carrément petit déjeuner
à
voilà
hahaha
là
l'équipe d'experts d'amazon
st
des peuples dataflux gayton profondeur
aurait porté les guerres
et si
l'ancien avant-centre de guerre
vaincus
bonsoir paris
merci
thank you my french peines copie
c'est ce que dans l'appartement
le destin